this is kigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn
conmigo is not just for students
teachers can use conmigo too by toggling
from the student mode to teacher mode in
any course and teachers can always
access kigo by selecting the AI
activities button located at the top of
the teacher dashboard kigo has many
exciting features that support teachers
and this video will showcase ways
teachers can use conmigo to create
course specific rubrics to enhance
learning EXP experiences for their
students once I select the co-creator
rubric feature kigo requests the
objective for the lesson and wants to
know what I'm planning to grade if I
know the standard I can include that as
well my students are going to be writing
a research paper for a science lesson
that we just completed the standard
is this I love that kigo knows exactly
what I'm talking about kigo will then
ask me a series of questions throughout
this process so that we are truly
collaborating to co-create the perfect
rubric that I want throughout the
process kigo is always going to want my
input and ask me if I want to make any
changes could you simplify the
explanation a bit for my students ah
this is much better once I've answered
all of K Migo's questions the Magic
Begins and kigo creates a rubric that is
detailed and specific so my students
will know exactly what they're being
graded on and if I have any e students I
can always ask kigo to translate the
rubric for my students or my parents
this is saving me so much time thank you
so much
kigo